Ці кадри записані з однієї з найгарячіших точок фронту - поблизу Бахмута.
У священний для всіх мусульман місяць Рамадан Саїд Імсагілов цитує Коран під звуки ворожої артилерії.
Мені робити це абсолютно не важко.
Мені не страшно ні вибухів, не пострілів.
Я взагалі нікого і нічого не боюсь, крім Аллаха.
Тринадцять років поспіль чоловік був ісламським духовним лідером в Україні.
Нині Саїд служить у ЗСУ.
Коли я був муфтієм, то намагався рятувати людей духовно.
А зараз на війні ми рятуємо життя людей.
Саїд пішов добровольцем до ЗСУ із початком повномасштабного вторгнення росіян в Україну.
На фронті колишній муфтій служить бойовим медиком:
керує автівкою швидкої та евакуює поранених солдат.
Каже, порятунок людей завжди вважав своєю місією.
Коли ми веземо людину ще при свідомості, з нею постійно потрібно тримати контакт,
щоб вона якось чіплялася за це життя.
Я, можна сказати, продовжую свою духовну роботу, але вже на більш важливому рівні.
Бо легко сидіти в мечеті і розповідати людям, яким їм бути,
і важко робити це там, де бруд, де смерть і де люди помирають.
Попри щоденні обстріли і стрес, Саїд дотримується ритуалів Рамадану
- постить від світанку до заходу сонця.
Він, як і багато років до того, продовжує духовно підтримувати інших мусульман
- але тепер вже у війську.
У перервах між обстрілами Саїд збирає побратимів на молитву.
Потрібно мотивувати людей.
Людей ми мотивуємо тим, що ми їм розповідаємо те, що написано в Корані,
приклади з життя пророка Мухаммеда, про його моральні цінності, настанови ісламу.
Це допомагає людям триматися.
Бо ми вже більше року повномасштабної війни опираємося ворогу,
який набагато більший за нас, набагато чисельніший, краще озброєний.
Тутешня мечеть - остання мусульманська святиня у цьому районі Донеччини.
Втім, її неодноразово обстрілювали росіяни.
Від іншої мечеті у місті Бахмут, де Саїд молився щодня минулого року під час служби, лишилася руїна.
Усі наслідки обстрілів, в тому числі і цивільної інфраструктури, Саїд фільмує на камеру.
Дві вирви від С-300. Загиблі цивільні!
Тим, що вижили, ASAP Rescue надає допомогу.
А це просто те, що залишилось від будинку, в якому жили цивільні мешканці!
Коли у нас є якийсь час між евакуаціями - бувають дні, страшні дні.
А бувають дні, коли потік поранених непостійний.
І в тебе є час, коли ти сидиш там, де стріляють і вибухає.
Ти не знаєш, чим зайнятися.
Можна читати книжку, а можна робити щось корисне для своєї країни.
У 2014 році - на початку вторгнення росіян в Україну -
Саїд жив і служив у мечеті в Донецьку.
Разом з родиною він був змушений покинути домівку.
Як релігійний лідер він тоді звертався до всіх мусульман Росії
і закликав засудити агресію та не брати у ній участі.
Після дев'яти років війни та того, що чоловік сам побачив на фронті,
він впевнений: ті росіяни, які називають себе мусульманами
і при цьому обстрілюють Україну і святині ісламу на українській території
- злочинці, які не можуть представляти його релігію.
Серед них і так званий чеченський лідер Рамзан Кадиров.
Мусульманському світу такі лідери думок, як Кадиров,
як російські муфтії і релігійні діячі кажуть, що вони боряться із сатанізмом, з шайтаном в Україні.
Що святий обов'язок всіх мусульман
- допомагати Росії воювати проти України.
І вони брешуть! Вони вигадують різні фейки:
нібито українці нарізають сало на Корані. Ну це смішно!
Аби давати відсіч ще й інформаційним атакам росіян та їхній пропаганді,
Саїд регулярно записує відеозвернення до своїх одновірців
з усього світу та показує їм правду про війну просто з передової.
Я борюся за майбутнє своєї країни.
Я записую певні звернення, певні меседжі,
читання Корану із зони бойових дій.
І це показую мусульманам з усього світу.
І якщо той же Кадиров чи муфтій російський зможе приїхати
і зробити те, що роблю я, ну, хай приїжджають! Ніхто не приїде!
Саїд молиться за перемогу України
і обіцяє: робитиме це доти, доки триватиме війна.